in the previous videos we have seen a
few applications of semi-definite
programming today we will take a look at
a different problem called max cut
this is really my favorite application
which is the reason why i left it for
last
this innocent looking problem that has
to do with catching graphs in two pieces
is in fact an np-hard problem which in
layman's terms means that if you could
solve it efficiently you get a million
dollar price at the risk of
disappointing some of you i must say
that we will not be solving the maxcus
problem exactly today but we will see an
approximation algorithm based on
semi-definite programming with an
approximation ratio of 87
what does approximation mean in this
context and how does it work and where
is this 87 percent coming from
and how does it all relate to the famous
p equal np question
well i guess that's what we're here to
find out
[Music]
so where is max cut let's forget about
the max part for now what does it mean
to cut a graph for that you first need a
graph or in other terms a bunch of notes
and edges between them
to cut the graph you need to color each
node with either one of two colors for
example either blue or red the value of
the cut is then the number of broken
edges or in other terms edges that have
their endpoints colored with two
different colors
to make things a little bit more formal
we assign to each node a variable x i
that encodes the color of that note for
example we can take one to mean blue and
-1 to mean red the nice thing about this
encoding is that for two nodes i and j x
i times x j equals to one if and only if
x i equals x j
and equals to minus one otherwise so if
you wanna know whether an edge is broken
by the cut or not we can look at the
quantity 1 minus x i times x j over 2
which is like a binary variable it's
equal to 1 if the edge is broken by the
cut and 0 otherwise
with this notation the value of a cut of
a graph like this one is given by the
sum of the quantity one minus x i x j
over two
and the max cut problem as the name
indicates is about finding suitable
values for the variables x i to make
this quantity as large as possible
this innocent looking problem is
actually notoriously difficult to solve
especially for graphs with a large
number of nodes and edges the best
algorithms that we know of today that
solve this problem are not that
different from the naive algorithm that
tries every possible combination of
colors and picks the best one and there
are two to the n such combinations so
this algorithm becomes quickly
infeasible in fact if you can find an
algorithm whose running time is bounded
by some power of n instead of two to the
n you would automatically solve the p
equal np question one of the millennium
price problems that comes amongst other
things with a million dollar cash prize
and a legendary status in the math and
computer science communities
so fair to say we will not be solving
this problem exactly today but we can
try to find approximate solutions and by
that i mean find the cat whose value is
at least a half or three quarters or
more generally some constant c
of the value of the maximum cut this
constant c is called the approximation
ratio the closest it is to one the
better the approximation algorithm is
let's start with something basic what if
we assign colors randomly to the nodes
what approximation ratio can we achieve
with this simple algorithm well this is
a probabilistic algorithm so its
performance will vary but on average
each edge has probability one half to be
broken by the cut and probability one
half not to be
in expectation each edge will then count
as one half towards the value of the cut
and if we sum across edges we get a cut
whose value is half the number of the
edges and in particular it's at least
half the value of the maximal cut can we
do better than 50
the answer is yes by using semi-definite
programming gomens and williamson were
able to achieve an approximation ratio
of 87 percent
and is their method that i want to share
with you today
their method can actually be applied to
any integer optimization problem or in
other words any optimization problem
where the decision variables can take
only two values one and minus one the
method is called a semi-definite
relaxation because of the following idea
instead of allowing only the two scalar
values one and minus one for each
variable x i we will allow each x i to
be a vector of norm one
and whenever we have a product of an x i
with some x j we'll replace that with x
i transpose x j and by doing this
relaxation we actually get a
semi-definite program
this is because if you take the matrix
of all inner products and let's call it
x for example
this matrix is positive semi-definite
and we can rewrite our optimization
problem in terms of this matrix x alone
if this step seems unclear to you make
sure to rewatch the second video of this
series which explains this step in more
details
and unlike integer programs we have very
efficient solvers for semi-definite
programs so we can solve this problem to
get the optimal matrix x to which we
apply the square root operation to get
the vector as x i
but remember at the end of the day to
get a cut we need the x i's to be
scalars so how do we go from unit
vectors to scalars
this step is called rounding and it's
usually the most challenging step in any
semi-definite relaxation
gomens and williamson proposed a very
elegant way to do it since the vectors
have norm1 we can view them as points on
the sphere
from there we can simply generate a
random hyperplane and assign the value
-1 to all the vectors that fall on one
side and the value plus one to the
others
concretely you do this by generating the
normal vector to this hyperplane from a
gaussian distribution for example and
consider its inner product with each one
of the vectors x i if the inner product
is negative you assign the value minus
one and if it's positive you assign plus
one and that's it
this is actually one of those things
that is easier to do than to explain so
let's jump to python and see how this is
done so let's say that the graph is
given to you as a list of edges
and we want to find a good cut for this
graph using gomez and williamson's
method we are going to solve a
semi-definite program so let's import
cvx pi
declare our matrix x to be positive
semi-definite and set the diagonals to 1
because we want unit vectors and set our
objective function appropriately after
calling the solve method we obtain the
following positive summary definite
matrix x to which we apply the matrix
square root function to get our vectors
x i keep in mind that these vectors
would have the same dimension as the
matrix x which is 5 in this case but we
plot them here in three dimensions just
for illustrative purposes
we then generate a random hyperplane and
pick labels for our nodes according to
which side they fall on of this
hyperplane
and finally after all of this work this
is the cut that you get and you can
check that the value of this particular
cat is equal to 5.
to summarize what we have seen so far we
first modified the original problem to
make it about vectors then we rounded
those vectors back to scalars
but the big question now is how does the
solution to the modified problem relate
to the original problem
in other words
how good is the cut that we obtained by
the gomen and williamson's method the
exact analysis is a bit outside the
scope of this video but i will give you
the main intuition here so you can get
an appreciation for this method and if
you want you can look at the references
included in the description for more
details
let's focus on one edge at the time for
example the edge between node i and node
j for these two nodes we have two
vectors x i and s j that were returned
by our semi-definite program and we
rounded them by looking at which side of
this random hyperplane they fall on
here's a question for you what is the
probability that the rounding leads to
different labels for these two notes
which would lead to this edge being part
of the cut
when you think about this question for
some time you realize that it has to do
with the angle theta between x i and x j
if the random hyperplane falls inside
this angle the two nodes will have
different labels otherwise they will
share the same label so the probability
that they get different labels is theta
over pi
the sum of these probabilities across
edges is the expectation of the value of
the cut that we obtained by this
rounding technique
how does this quantity relate to our
modified objective function
or more precisely how does theta i j
over pi relate to 1 minus x i transpose
x j over 2.
since x i and x j are unit vectors their
inner product is equal to cosine of
theta
so the question now is how does theta
over pi relate to 1 minus cos theta over
2 can we bound the ratio between the two
actually let's plot this ratio as a
function of data you can see that it has
a minimum somewhere here
which is equal to approximately 0.87
this means that the cut that we get
after the rounding procedure is at least
87 percent of the value of the objective
value of our semi-definite program which
was itself a relaxation of the original
max cat problem
in other words gomen and williamson's
method is an approximation algorithm
with an approximation ratio of 87
percent which is very neat
this is really the stage of the art this
is the best algorithm that we know of
that runs in polynomial time
this ratio of 87 percent seems like an
arbitrary numerical constant and
morally you would expect that with a
little bit of work we should be able to
do better
but assuming the unique game conjecture
which is a widely believed conjecture in
computer science
this approximation ratio is probably the
best possible in the sense that if you
could achieve an approximation ratio of
even 88
then that would imply that p equal np
and all the consequences that would
follow
if this does not blow your minds i don't
know it will
this is saying that unless p equal np
which would be some earth shattering
used
this simple algorithm based on
semi-definite programming is not only
good it is actually the best possible
algorithm which goes to show you the
true power hidden behind this seemingly
naive question that we asked in the
beginning of this series about how to
define positive matrices this is a good
place to end this series now that we
have come a full circle
i must emphasize here of course that my
goal of this series is not to give a
full overview of everything that's going
to be done with semi-definite
programming that would make this video
the longest on youtube by far but i
tried to present few illustrative
examples from completely different
fields so that hopefully you could
appreciate the breadth of applications
that are possible with semi-definite
programming as usual if you like the
video please make sure to like and
subscribe and see you next time